thank you I'm glad to be here so I'll
talk about research collaborations with
the Census Bureau that are being
implemented in the 2020 decennial of
population and housing this is the list
of the people who did all the hard work
so the disclaimer so I'm here as an
academic researcher so all the
statements conclusions and so on in this
talk are my own they're not official
policy of the Census Bureau so I'll talk
traduced a problem we'll talk about the
two main challenges were we have to deal
with which we call schema extension and
invariance and I'll discuss the details
of the top-down algorithm that was used
in there it 2018 end-to-end test and
then a long-standing question about
which version of difference or privacy
we should use so a few slides on that at
the end so if I use any Ackerman's like
gasps it's the disclosure avoidance
system that's the formal name for the
differential privacy module that we'll
be running so our goal is to publish a
histogram using billions of cells using
formal privacy so the cell has a lot of
attributes one of them is location which
is hierarchical as John mentioned we
have national level state county tract
block group which is a collection of
blocks and then finally at the block so
there are roughly six million blocks in
the data we're developing on ethnicity
has two variables race 63 we're looking
at whether someone's voting age or not
so there are two values there and then
there's also a residence type which is
does the person live in a household or
do they live in a group quarters if they
live in a group quarters who provide
this group quarters code which so total
there's eight value eight values there
so fortunately for us the workload is
hierarchical basically at every unit of
geography
we have counting queries about the
demographics there so for example if you
look at this PL 94 171 file from 2010 it
contains redistricting data and advanced
group quarters summary files contains
additional information about people who
live in group quarters these are the
first few tables that we were targeting
with the algorithm so property of the
data it's very sparse if you multiply it
out there roughly 12 billion cells and
if you count everyone right around 300
million people if you want the exact
number John will tell you so our query
workload has about 641 non identity
queries per geo unit so overall with all
the levels of aggregation we have we
have 3.6 billion queries and then we
also have the identity queries so for
every demographic category how many
people have that so that's roughly 12
billion there and this ensures that when
we set epsilon to infinity we recover
the original data okay so the formal
notion of privacy we're using currently
as differential privacy so I'm assuming
most of you are familiar with this so
basically we're looking at bounded
differential privacy meaning that we
know the total number of people that's
going to be fixed and the notion of what
differs between two databases is we're
allowing one page of the census
questionnaire which is basic information
about one person we're allowing one of
those changes if you're interested in
the questionnaire you can look at
summary file 1 and at the end in one of
the appendices they have the actual
questionnaire so some things to note
about this definition we actually have
multiple tables so there is a person's
level table a households level table a
group quarters table and geographic
boundaries table so the person's table
is demographics about each person one
person affects one row so if they
changed their census questionnaire they
change that row we have a households
table which talks about the people in a
household what is the household type
what is the race of the householder and
in here one person can modify one row
but only in a bounded way they said it
can't completely modify a household
because that depends on the rest of the
people there so in particular this is
different from a lot of relational
models for differential privacy
especially ubers model so I think that's
something worth noting here we have a
group quarters table which is very
similar to the households table except
different questions are asked about
group quarters populations and then
finally there are geographic boundaries
those are defined in collaboration with
States and while they do depend on
people we treat that as something that
doesn't have any protection any question
so if you have questions just feel free
to ask and if I'm running out of time
I'll leave anur them ok so here are
requirements we have to create microdata
so the reason we have to create micro
data is first it means that all of the
tables all the summary statistics we
create are going to be consistent with
each other you're not going to get two
different answers for the same query by
looking at two different tables another
reason is the output of our system goes
into a tabulation system and it expects
micro data so that's the format we
create so microdata is a little bit hard
to work with but it's essentially
equivalent to a histogram with
non-negative integer counts so when I
say histogram I'm referring both to the
histogram itself and also to the micro
data okay so one thing to note here is
not a non-negative integer counts are
some things that a lot of the literature
ignored but it's a crucial property for
us in terms of practical things we have
a time limit the whole system has to run
within a certain number of days so we're
implementing it in spark which has its
own challenges we're using the cloud and
instead of writing our own optimizer
routines are actually using
commercial-grade optimizers okay so two
challenges we have one is we have to run
our system before all the data are
available so because some surveys are
complex and there's a lot goes on before
we even see the data for disclosure
control we're first going to see the
redistricting data first we're going to
have to create
a differentially private version of that
then we're going to get more data and
we'll have to create a differentially
private version of summary file one
which will have to be consistent with PL
94 then there's going to be an earl rule
update which has a little bit more
information and there that's not the end
there's going to be a lot more
tabulations that come after this so in
addition to creating the data piecemeal
we have to be consistent with external
pieces of knowledge and I'll discuss if
this means a little bit later so we have
to be consistent with external power
knowledge and with our prior releases ok
so there's some data sets that are
effectively public one of them is called
the Luka data set which contains both
the address lists that census is going
to be using so in particular first that
means that the number of housing units
in every block is known the number of
group quarters of each type in every
block is essentially known these are so
one decision would have is that the
number of occupied group quarters
facilities in each block is assumed to
be known and invariant so our published
data has to be consistent with this
information one of the reasons for
consistency's policy decisions another
is to make sure that people trust the
data because if you have two separate
sources of information given completely
different results well that increases
trust issues okay so some information is
just going to be declared public as a
policy decision in 2010 the population
and each block was an invariant the
number of occupied housing units in each
block was in that in invariant and then
if you know that the number of occupied
housing units corresponds to the number
of householders you know that the number
of householders in each block is
considered an invariant later on I'll
give you a link to some reading and if
you want to figure out more invariants
you can deduce them from that document
so basically we have this term
invariance these are queries in the
truth in the data that have to have the
same answer in the differentially
private data that we create so our
algorithms are still differentially
private but this changes the privacy
semantics because we have to account for
releasing the invariants along with
releasing the differ
surely private summaries so the privacy
semantics become very awkward we've been
working on a paper for it seems like
years it's been rewritten many times and
we're still not very happy with it but
aside from the semantics part the
computational problems become
np-complete okay so those are
environments we have another name for
restrictions on the data that don't
depend on the actual data set itself and
these are structural zeros it's not
always a good term the song I mean it's
called structural zeros because some
counts are supposed to be zero for
example we can't have any householders
that are under 14 but other structural
properties like the number of
householders is greater than equal to
number of spouses and unmarried partners
of householders it has to hold so I have
differentially so I have a data set and
then I compute I have a differential
differentially private computation over
it and I can release the output but at
the same time the same entity who might
be releasing additional information for
example if we release the exact number
of people in each block right what does
that mean for your privacy when we
combine both of those together it's a
composition between differential privacy
and a non differentially private
computation
okay so so let's talk about these two
I'll define problems so the first one we
call the incremental schema extension
okay so basically we create microdata
that's a through a differentially
private process and then we add columns
to it also satisfying absalom
differential privacy for example suppose
we start with a table we create just a
national statistics about race ethnicity
and voting age status whether someone's
voting age or not later on we can attack
on the state attributes so we can for
all of these differential privacy people
we create we add a state and then later
on we add a county to them and so on
okay so this is the kind of problem that
we're trying to solve it's necessary
first because we don't have all of the
information available at once but it's
also useful for scalability so if we
take all of the well the full schema so
all of the columns we eventually want to
tack on it's just not going to fit in
memory the comment the common paradigm
for differentially private algorithm is
first creating measurements so noisy
estimate so for queries and then
post-process them to create the micro
data so this optimization problem is not
going to fit into main memory if we try
to do everything at once second problem
is consistency with external knowledge
so external knowledge means we have some
information about the full histogram
that we want to create at the end but
we're making a piecemeal so when we
create this and we start adding columns
we want to make sure that when we create
this data we can always extend it to a
full table that will satisfy all of the
constraints and this decision problem
what we created can it be extended is
np-complete in general
okay so because the invariance causes so
many headaches that's actually where we
spend most of our time on we're going to
talk about just the general framework
for how we add columns and then later on
add in the invariants so as I said
earlier the histogram is way too big to
fit in memory we have to create it in
pieces so what we're going to do is
we're going to take person level
demographics at the national level and
create a non-negative integer histogram
once we do that then we're going to
create a non-negative integer histograms
of demographics at each state and then
we have to have a consistency
requirement that when you add up the
demographics from every state you get
the national level histogram once we do
that then we recursively create the
county level histograms of tract level
histograms block group and block level
histograms so our hierarchy has six
levels so since there are you know 50
states plus DC so we typically say 51
States and then around 3000 counties and
then 6 million blocks the number of
optimization problems we have to solve
increases as we go down the hierarchy
but the size of the optimization
problems decrease because when we see
that something is sparse at a state
level we inherit that sparsity when we
push it down to the county level so
variables that are 0 at some point will
stay 0 and that allows us to create
fewer variables and to do all of this
efficiently
so the total u.s. population is not
protected and that is a crucial part of
the first step of our algorithm so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
our population level true histogram
we're going to have a workload for the
you can think of these as the pl 94
tables or the SF 1 population tables and
we use a new technique called the high
dimensional matrix mechanism to find out
which linear queries we should ask
that'll allow us to estimate these
answers most accurately so we're gonna
get this query work these strategy
queries we're going to apply them to the
true histogram add some noise to satisfy
differential privacy and then we're
gonna have noisy measurements so what
we're gonna first going to do to create
the national level histogram they solved
this optimization problem so we want to
create this synthetic microdata h star
such that it answers the queries almost
exactly almost matches the noisy query
answers subject to some constraints like
we have this population total in variant
and we have it has to be non-negative
right now I left out the integer part so
this solve is very fast and it gives us
our non-negative fractional histogram of
population demographics and then we need
to convert it into an integer histogram
so we round it using a linear program
which is equivalent to this so basically
we have our fractional counts we want to
create this new histogram with integers
that doesn't deviate from too much from
it has to be non-negative we want to
make it rounding so that we bound how
much each cell can differ and then
finally we want to make sure that for
every demographics combination
yeah a little bug here but basically if
every demographics combination as to
okay that the total number of people has
to be the same and previously we said
this to be the actual population of the
United States which is an integer so
this becomes feasible so if you write
this out
the constraint matrix is totally in a
modular we're gonna be repeating this a
lot so because it's Tom
we have integer feasibility and instead
of making this an integer program we can
actually use linear programming
techniques to solve it so groobie is
using barrier plus crossover to solve
this problem but just to be safe we do a
square will be to solve it as an integer
program but it's fast because of this
property
yeah instead of started making these
none of these counts to be real numbers
by adding noise you might think of a
different algorithm which uses the extra
sort of a discretized Laplace did you
think of that and then you're only
adding integers to these yes we did
that's a good question so we could you
know we have our query workload which
these are all counting queries and we
can use the geometric mechanism turns to
them but if we want to get more accuracy
we actually use the high dimensional
matrix mechanism which gives us a
different set of queries to ask and to
get differential privacy here so the
coefficients of these queries are real
numbers not integers and then we have to
use the Laplace mechanism even if we
didn't use this the fact that we want
this constraint over here already means
that we might be getting non integer
solutions so if you're well at the
Google method firstly then so if you're
peccary symmetric is the total variation
distance why do you use the output
distance okay so it's our we're evolving
our optometric for for accuracy so the
total l1 distance is just one number we
can present the policy people tell you
where yes we're constantly improving it
second the reason we're doing L to solve
there are two reasons one is it's fast
and the other is at least this one is
guaranteed to put the queries together
two minima to reduce the variance
compared to compared to this if you
forget about this non negativity
constraint it's provable that the
queries answered from here have lower
variance than
okay so then we round and then we
recurse down the states so we have none
negative integer histogram at the
national level we want to do the same
thing for the state so first anything
that is zero at the national level stays
zero and so we don't have to create
variables an optimization problem so for
each state we use HTML again to find the
queries to ask we add noise and so now
we have a set of measurements for every
state and we have similar but not
exactly the same solve process so first
linear square linear least squares saw
followed by a linear optimization
problem
okay so we have our national level
histogram that's fixed now we have our
state level measurements and so we want
to create measurements fractional
histograms at each state that and whose
query answers match these pretty closely
and that add up to the national
histogram so we solved this optimization
problem basically minimize the distance
between the noisy measurements and the
answers from our synthetic histograms
and this last constraint is the
consistency constraint the states have
to add up to the national level
okay so again we round it using a linear
program the same as before except we
have this added constraint that the
states the integer state solutions have
to add up to the integer national
solution
in the fraction of all of the this
various increased predators because of
the small negative projection it's hard
to say
we definitely notice a bias when we
aggregate over other types of queries
it's the bias the bias is increasing
because you know some if something is
zero the only thing could do is move up
to be positive so we're exploring how to
deal with that that's a definitely big
issue
and then we recurse so now that we have
state-level demographics histograms we
can process them independently so for
each state we generate its county level
measurements and then do our solves to
create the county level histograms then
once we get once we have the county
specs when we do the tract the block
groups the blocks one sits at the block
level we convert it back into micro data
so overall this whole process takes
about twenty twenty thousand lines of
code plus another 60,000 more supporting
code to glue it into the rest of the
system that's not everything so like I
said most of our time is spent dealing
with invariants so basically the final
data once we've created it with all of
its fields has to satisfy mostly linear
constraints so this is roughly what we
started with
and then we started then we added the
states counties
okay so once we had everything we have
some linear constraints that have to be
satisfied and so so again we have to
worry about if you publish some exact
statistics about the data worth it due
to the privacy semantics and then how do
we make the algorithm enforce those
constraints both in both cases it's
complicated
so just to give you an idea of some of
the problems who have been dealing with
here's a very simple example suppose
we're just looking at a two-level
geographic hierarchy and we're only
interested in whether people live in
let's say a male only dorm female only
dorm or a coed dorm so we have a small
college town there are two regions we
have some aggregate statistics for a
number of people in each dorm type and
we have their differentially private
counterparts and our question is given
this can we extend it at region
information so that it's consistent with
public knowledge in this example the
knowledge is that each region over here
hundred students hundred students they
all live in dorms all dorms are occupied
first region has zero male only dorms
and the second region has zero female
only dorms this is the simplest example
we could find that has some of these
where properties so like I said we
created these differentially private
counts we want to extend it to the
region so our question is are these
counts that we generated consistent with
background knowledge so let's talk about
what would this mean so obviously these
will have to have some restrictions we
can't have arbitrary counts okay so we
can say well alright so we know that
there is one male only dorm one female
only dorm and two co-ed dorms all of
them are occupied so clearly we should
have at least one person living animal
only dorm at least one in a female only
dorm at least two in co-ed and total
population is 200
so these are I guess rather
straightforward but the question is are
we done and turns out this is not quite
correct
so suppose we had these kind of counts
which satisfy all the constraints lifts
listed above so if you think about it
this is incorrect for subtle reason
there's only one male lonely dorm over
here population of this region is 100
and so we cannot have 101 people living
in male-only dorms if we want to extend
this to be consistent with here it's not
valid the reason is that the different
constraints all the interact in ways
that are not very nice so we have
several hammers for solving these
problems one is to use for a Motzkin
elimination which allows us to automate
some times so for example these
constraints we've proved automatically
for for these counts in order to allow
them to be extended to this region
another way is network flows so network
flows is also a nice hammer but it
doesn't apply in all situations you can
reduce the problem to a network flow
problem by getting rid of all the
greater equal to some constant
constraints setting them to here use the
max-flow min-cut theorem analyze the
cuts and come up with essentially the
same constraints
so we can formalize this problem as we
have a schema that we start with which
is basically a set of table columns we
have a super side of it which is the
extended schema we have a table
satisfying the the first scheme we have
a table microdata table
that satisfies the first schema and we'd
like to generate a table T that
satisfies the larger scheme we're given
a set of constraints on this larger
table for example the total population
in each region the presence and absence
of occupied dorms and we want to figure
out what does C imply about t0 okay so
we have a constraints C sort of
constraints that this thing this t0 has
to satisfy and our question is how do we
find them so we have basically we can't
have arbitrary constraints we have to
have C 0 has to be necessary and
sufficient so if basically something on
the true tape and the entire table is
true then it must be true on the
projection with T 0 as the projection of
the full table and conversely if
something is true on this there has to
exist an extension
so the question is how do we find them
in general this is and be complete even
if we have a schema with two attributes
and another and the full table has three
attributes probably see that you can
easily encode a three-set problem this
way but three set problems can be nasty
sometimes
it turns out that even if you have some
really well-behaved nice-looking
constraints such as marginals to one way
marginals in each region
this becomes np-complete as long as the
number of regions is three or more and
it's np-complete and the number of rows
and columns okay so that's the bad news
but the good news is we have a tool for
you Motzkin elimination which will
automatically generate our constraints
it does have some not very nice
complexity and the other problem is it
gives us linear constraints so we know
that there is a fractional extension
we're not always sure that there's an
integer extension usually we have to
prove this by hand or use some arguments
with network flows to do that okay so
let's put everything together so we want
to generate a national-level
differentially private histogram but we
have some implied constraints that we
generate through various means about
what national level statistics what
constraints they have to satisfy in
order for us to be able to extend it by
adding additional columns and
geographies we get our noisy
measurements we set up first or l2
solved the only difference is we added
some more conditions that are implied
constraints have to be satisfied then we
have our rounding solve which again we
take our linear solve and add these
constraints okay so we ask a row B to
solve this as an integer problem but it
uses linear programming techniques if
essentially if this is if this matrix is
totally in a modular so in most of our
cases we do have a tum matrix and
sometimes we're not quite sure if it's
Tom but given our objec
the function on the right hand side it
seems that they're nice enough to give
us integer solutions
so basically implied constraints we did
especially by hand part and then verify
using automated techniques we have the
l2 Sol followed by the l1 solve so in
some cases we have nice constraints
integer optimal solutions exist and
there we can find them quickly sometimes
there solve is very slow in these cases
we think that it extends to a tum tum
problem but not quite sure yet okay so
the example of the of the ones where the
solve is the slow is the one that I
showed you before it's we have group
quarters occupied group quarters of
different types in different regions so
in general in the census when we want to
publish PL 94 and SF 1 the GQ is going
to have the group quarters are gonna
have three digit codes that are might be
invariant so I can't say for sure but
that's the way it seems right now it's
similar college dorm example but instead
of having three types of group quarters
there are 28 types and then they have
subtypes because they have restrictions
on age and who can live there so the
implied constraints that we generate are
quite big so 2 to 28 of them in the
general case we don't think that all of
them are necessary so if we use network
flow we can actually reduce this number
substantially so the constraints
basically look like for every combien
combination of group quarters so us as a
combination of group quarters we look at
the total population of group quarters
who live in gqueues of this type and it
has to be bounded by a constant C which
we have to compute from the data
okay so when we look at this the
constraint matrix is not totally in the
modular but using that workflows we can
prove that we got integer solutions and
then you might be asking me well if you
have network flows why isn't it Tom it's
because our constraints are on the
capacities of the edges rather than just
encoding the network structure so in
general the can the environment that
we've been asked to look at they keep
changing and sometimes they're slow
sometimes they're fast sometimes we
don't know how to do them so we have
some backup strategies just in case so
our fine our last line of defense is
called the failsafe
basically if I solve fails at some point
for example let's say we're generating
county-level histograms and we just
cannot find a feasible solution what
we're going to do is we're going to drop
the requirement that everything adds up
to the parent so we're going to drop the
requirement that the population totals
in each demographic category add up to
the state level or county level
population instead we're going to use
the weaker requirement where some linear
queries have to match the parent but not
every query so once we do this we
generate the children and then we
recompute the county based on the sum of
the tracks
so we found that this is not very good
for accuracy but it does maintain the
invariance the other approach is the
minimal schema approach and that goal of
that is to find the smallest set of
attributes that cover all of the
invariants and the geography so if we
find those and then adding other columns
that are not involved in the invariants
would be easy so if this problem with
all levels of geography can fit in
memory then we can just do it in one
pass and we don't have to worry about
implied constraints and then we can
start extending the other ones okay and
then finally there's another approach
which is in between these two and that
we know that not all constraints are
necessary and so one standard integer
programming technique is to use cutting
planes so we have multiple solves to
find the right constraints that we need
so we've explored many invariants the
actual choice of the invariants is a
policy decision so our job is just to
support them and give advice basically
saying how does this affect privacy
semantics and what happens to our
ability to actually generate data that
satisfy those constraints the current
set of invariants that we are looking at
right now
is that the state population totals are
invariant for the purposes of
apportionment the number of occupied
group quarters facilities of each types
of the 28 types in each block is
invariant the total number of housing
units is invariant so some of them might
be vacant some of them might be occupied
but the total is invariant and then we
have some of the other information about
group quarters some of them have age
restrictions for example in nursing
homes some of them have sex restrictions
like female only male only or co-ed and
then we have a bunch of structural zeros
like the ones I mentioned earlier okay
if you're interested in what happened in
2010 and earlier here's a link for the
disclosure voidance discussion from
which you can infer additional
invariants that were used in to any time
okay
so there have been some questions about
why were you seeing pure differential
privacy rather than concentrated or any
differential privacy that is a good
question so there are some technical
issues and some policy issues that make
it a little bit hard but we are planning
to explore it so right now basically
we're using pure DP with la plaza noise
sometimes geometric mechanism we're
finding some experiments with our DP and
DC DP but for some initial setup for the
experiments and some initial findings
some numerical findings are first we
like the numerical probability to be
really small basically if you think of
the classical approximate differentially
private algorithm that with some
probability chooses a random record and
releases it we want to minimize that
probability of that happening
so if you think of it as a roughly 400
million people and we want one in a
million chance of releasing anyone's
record we would be studying epsilon
Delta sorry if we one day use moment
accountant and split the privacy budget
equally across the six levels of our
geographic hierarchy these are roughly
the variances that we get for different
settings of epsilon so currently it
looks like the laplace variance would be
smaller than the gaussian variance or
equivalent Epsilon's
okay but even though the Gaussian
variance is larger than the plus the
tails are smaller and if the tails are
smaller we're going to have fewer
outliers in the sense of fewer large
noise values and that can affect our
post-processing steps
it also affects some of the error
measures if we don't look at Barron's
but if you look at other ones another
possibility is that the query workload
might be better tuned for our DP than
for Laplace noise because we'd be
looking at l2 sensitivity instead of l1
sensitivity so we are planning
experiments said these numbers say we're
not too optimistic but something could
improve and then of course we also have
a lot of other things to do so I don't
know what is the time frame for getting
these right okay so we have lots of time
for questions
[Applause]
what question so you know the problem
with the gqueues ID they're real numbers
behind that why aren't you just adding
noise to those and then once you produce
this micro Daddy control the whole thing
in a selectable editing system with the
foyer Motzkin eliminations making
updates your example you had but you
knew the margins but there must be real
counts underlying it okay so I will not
put up real data here so it is made up
but we had the same issues where we had
the wrong constraints and our solves
failed okay we could you know just do
whatever and then have the
post-processing step later but then it's
much harder to optimize so the accuracy
could separate that it's all it's a
really large-scale problem that's
sometimes best to handle piecewise so
maybe this is also a question for John
but have you
is there a decision that the census that
what will ultimately bitterly released
is only the final results of the but
that the processing or also the kind of
raw noisy measurements that were made at
each step because I could imagine that
there might be advances over the next
ten years for example people might find
other ways of post-processing those
measurements pre-board want to play with
other ways
I can answer the non-policy version of
that question so we are planning to save
the noise and in addition to better
post-processing another thing we can do
with differential privacy is if after
five years we decide it's okay to
allocate more privacy budget to it and
increase the accuracy we don't generate
fresh noise we can use techniques like
noise down to make the existing queries
more accurate
so I mentioned one of the other one that
you can have is a composition okay so
this accounts the advanced composition
and thus it comes forward so we split it
across six levels I mean if we just
looked at the national level histogram
the full privacy budget this would look
so much more favorable to Laplace but
because we have six levels of geographic
hierarchy we have advanced composition
using moment accountant versus just
normal composition for laplace and so
this is what the numbers look like right
now
so the other benefit right is in the
tails and that's something that could
help us control the tails with the dump
well okay so that will put us into
approximate differential privacy not RDP
because now we're actually having this
event where something bad happens
plus the but the moment accountant works
differently for Laplace than for
Gaussian that's the other
so the Delta you're picking here is
quite small in a particular IDP CBP
algorithms don't actually just wondering
what's happen if you picked well you can
pick a Delta so that RDP does better
that's a short answer
the longer answer is privacy semantics
right now for Z CDP and RDP right
they're all based on approximate
difference or privacy say if you had
better ways of setting the parameters I
mean this is just the default this is
what the literature says if you had
better ways of setting it we could again
choose to the parameters in a better way
but it has to be explainable to policy
people no integrals I think it's hard to
say that's like one possible
interpretation of this epsilon Delta RDP
is that with privilege here one minus
Delta your privacy is better than block
and from that perspective it's
meaningful to the deltas which is fifty
percent ten percent one percent so if we
can get we can set Delta to a point here
one and say that 99 percent of people do
enjoy privacy which is better than
whatever be out
go from that doesn't say anything about
99% of the people train but sadly
Jessica Delta find the one doesn't mean
the 99% of the people will enjoy
enterprise well thank you for the
correction with probability 99% any
given person will enjoy it better
privacy lengua a it's not its privilege
here
Oh Travis loss event for any single
person but the kind of semantics that
people want to hear are like the
simulation argument will say that for
any attacker with any prior right the
privacy additional laws and privacy
addition risk in disclosing some some
event is love I don't know if that kind
of equivalence has been shown from IDP
to something prior so I think we can
talk about this for hours so we can talk
about this for hours so let me just say
a challenge for you and Thomas is to
give us better semantics so right now
just explaining epsilon is very hard and
you're saying we'll just have this graph
for every epsilon
you don't have to convince me you have
to convince policy people and that's the
problem but we are set up to run with
our DP because we just need to change
our query workload and our accounting
for the privacy laws all right in some
of this discussion we
[Applause]